let's get back to the phones at
617-830-4750 and see what's on people's
minds let's go to our caller from the
785 area code 785 has been a very
controversial area code for the show we
have a long history with it
um who's calling today from 785 today
is that me yeah who's this hey david um
my name is brad i'm a senior in
at a at a high school in the 785 region
i don't
i'm new to watching you so i'm not
familiar with all the controversies
regarding my area code well let me just
put it this way
clearly you are not the kansas troll so
we can just skip any other discussions
and move on to what what you want to
talk about yeah
all right cool um i've got two questions
i don't know if that's too much but
please um so we have youtube twitch like
a bunch of
a variety of internet media now and
as far as i can tell with the type of
crowd i hang out with which is
a mix of right wingers and left wingers
a lot of young kids are being like
i don't want to be indoctrinated but are
being
fed a lot of abstract political theory
at a very young age and i heard you say
or actually i looked i looked at a
article about you that
said um you sort of critiqued sanders's
embrace of socialism last year like the
word socialism at least like pure
socialism not
democratic socialism and um do you think
that
that's going that's only a problem
within the older generation
being a a large voting bloc and do you
see that
problem that you pointed out of the word
socialism being embraced
going to like end soon when my
generation becomes a big part of the
voting bloc
well you you the answer to that question
is you will be answering that i can't
answer that if you're saying is your
generation going to embrace actual
socialism
i can't answer that for you because it's
up to your generation there's a couple
things i would say
one um the
future of socialism
in the united states is going to be
dictated by
really two primary things one
do the people saying they want it
actually know what it is
and part of the confusion i mean even
when you say socialism versus democratic
socialism
the the real question is socialism
versus social democracy democratic
socialism
as traditionally defined is socialism
what i
think you mean is social democracy in
the sort of northern european style
so the first question is going to be
does the word
socialism get completely redefined to
mean social democracy or are people in
your generation
actually clamoring for socializing the
means of production i mean to ask you
which do you mean when you talk about
socialism
that's a great question um i say a lot
of people who watch a lot of
like theory or read a lot of theory like
sort of are okay with the idea of
socializing
lots of industries like more than just
the resource industries that
um uh that venezuela and norway has done
like oils and stuff
but as as far as like uh
how they like express their views
through their voting and express their
views through to
like political candidates and such i
really only see as
a social democracy being like the only
way to express like
far left um thought now at least okay
so that gets directly into part two
which is
if you are an accelerationist then your
belief would be that the path to
socialism however you define it
is a sort of breakdown of the current
system that we have
to be rebuilt directly into socialism
my view is an incrementalist view
because
i believe that when you look at history
that's the way that it has worked
and so no matter what your definition of
socialism is whether it is
as far to the center as social democracy
or as far to the left as you know
marxist leninism or whatever
whatever it may be yeah um the next step
i believe is social democracy either way
so the immediate question is
is the entire left that is at social
democracy and
further left going to unite around
social democracy because i think
we should all recognize no matter what
we see as the end point that's the next
stop on the train so to speak most
definitely yeah
um i have one more question hopefully
this doesn't take too much time
sure but my question is is there any
political um
issue today that you believe um some
sort of violence is justified
for example like the rioters are would
you say they're justified in
property damage even though it's not
like all of them who are doing it
obviously as some right-wing pundits uh
try to make out the picture to be like
is there any structural issue in society
that you believe
the only way to get a large majority of
americans to like pay attention and wake
up to
um is through political violence to get
that message on tv
okay so this is a really big topic and a
great question let me say a few things
about it
first of all i'm gonna stop short of
like moralizing whether whether it's
morally justified to turn to to violence
to achieve political means
right now i want to stop because that's
just a kind of a matter of opinion
where i i'm gonna kind of take it from a
more pragmatic perspective number one
the question i would ask is
have other means short of violence been
tried
because if they haven't i think that we
should be trying those first
and as an example mass rallies in urban
centers
strategic defaults to [ __ ] the
financial system
strategic work call outs there's a whole
list of things i give in my my videos
that i've done about how activism can be
more effective than signing a petition
and calling your rep
that have not been tried yet and so for
me from a pragmatic perspective i would
try those things first before i go to
violence because there's a smaller risk
to the individuals doing them
the second part is from a practical
perspective
you can look at old videos of malcolm x
and martin luther king
weighing in on this issue i am much more
pragmatically aligned with martin luther
king who said
even if you can morally justify the
violence
in practice it very often ends up
hurting the very people
who we on the left are trying to help
through the violence and so i also don't
want to
suggest people do things which may
actually most hurt those we are trying
to help
so i don't know if that's an answer i'm
not answering the morality part of it
but i'm hoping i hope i'm giving you a
perspective on the practicality of it
yeah oh no that was a great answer it's
just that there's a
there's just a huge conversation like
whether
um i mean there was a book released 10
years ago called the new jim crow that's
like
a huge critique of the criminal justice
system now and it seems like
but not a lot has um changed policy wise
like
i don't i don't know if you saw the ad
um i believe it was earlier this year
but it was like trump
thing he passed major criminal justice
reform which is a joke
but yeah it's
yeah i was just i was just wondering
what your thoughts are on that topic
i'm a new viewer i haven't seen too much
of your videos but
i'm watching now so well i'm glad to
have you and uh
you're thinking about a lot of important
issues and i appreciate you calling in
yep you have a good one all right take
care uh okay
that is going to do it for live calls
for this week as always i do have to
apologize i throw myself at your mercy i
was not able to get to every caller
but we will take calls again and i hope
to hear from you next time we'll take a
quick break and be back with more show
right after this